assalamualaikum welcome to
everyone i'm just going to wait a couple
of more seconds here to see who else
arrives and then
we will get into the
book recommendations
for this video
hope everyone is doing well tonight
or what's evening for me so
okay let's see here um
so this
book recommendation
video is going to be a little bit
different i have some more
fiction material
and
some more history material
some on just general islamic thought so
inshallah let's get right into it
see what we can do here
all right then so the first book i want
to recommend
is
a fairly good book with respect to the
history of science within islamic
civilization
and some of the narratives surrounding
that history some of the erroneous
narratives surrounding the history and a
corrective to those narratives
and this is one of the main resources
that i use with with regard to
discussing
uh scientific history and islamic
civilization and this is by ahmed dalal
and it's called islam science and the
challenge of history
it's a very good book you can see this
one's quite tattered because i've used
it
quite extensively
but yes this is a
very very good book it's quite concise
it's a little bit over 200 pages with
footnotes but it's a very good academic
read
and it's highly recommended
with regard to the history of
science within islamic civilization it
gives all the facts that we have on hand
and it tries to
basically clarify
some of the misconceptions about that
history especially from the western
perspective because many people
within orientalist circles especially
like to assume that um
scientific history with islamic
civilization was primarily
you know contrary to religious thought
when in fact it was not
uh so this is a very good book okay
all righty then let's see what else we
got here
so another one here is
um
i've actually met him in person and i
believe i also
took a lecture from him at one point
uh this is another one by al parslan
and i can't pronounce his name properly
ever for some reason islamic scientific
tradition in history it's very thick
book uh very good uh is more of a
perception of islamic scientific history
from an ideological perspective more
about the ideas
of how it was formed etc so this is also
very good it's actually only part one i
don't think he's actually published part
two yet
so this is a very good book i got this
in malaysia as well
um so this is um
i'd say it's a very it's a very um
[Music]
comprehensive work so it's it's actually
quite it takes a lot of time to get
through but i think it's uh if you can
find it it's worthy of
of your reading okay
so
all right then let's see what else we
got here um this is also regarding
history but i it's about the caliphate
so it's the fall in the rise of the
islamic state by noah feldman a
researcher at harvard
he discusses how the caliphate actually
fell by trying to adopt modernistic
western norms of legal uh theory and
that is actually how the sharia was was
eventually undermined and the caliphate
fell apart so very fascinating very
concise read but worthy
of your reading time definitely if you
definitely want to understand how the
ottoman empire kind of fell apart
uh i think this is one of the best works
on the subject matter
okay so definitely definitely pick this
one up
it's a wonderful read and very concise
okay
let's see here
all right then um
more along the lines of islamic thought
in general islamic studies in general uh
this is one of my favorite books with
respect to
cataloging the modern interpretations of
the quran and where they come from so
the perspectives of western thinkers
so-called reformers and orthodox and
traditionalists so it goes to the entire
spectrum
of interpretation within the
contemporary muslim world and goes to
the background of those interpretations
where they came from initially where
they originated
and the main thinkers behind them but
this one is by massimo campanini the
quran modern muslim interpretations it's
actually a very concise book but highly
recommended if you want to understand
some of the perspectives within the
muslim world and how certain individuals
read in things into the quran or how
they read them from a traditional
perspective
okay also very good book
uh
finally within islamic studies i would
say this is one of the better books on
the market
probably the most comprehensive book
with respect to slavery and islam both
from a historical and legal perspective
and this is by jonathan jonathan brown
dr jonathan brown who i know personally
and work with
this is probably one of the best books
on the subject matter
if not the only real book on the subject
matter worthy of reading at this current
state
um
actually i've talked to him while he was
writing this book and he spent months
just
you know
just uh non-stop writing this it is full
of
a lot of juicy information a lot of
understanding of the subject matter
um it's definitely a must read
uh for any of you out there who are
concerned about the subject or just want
to know about it so
definitely worthy of your time it is a
robust academic work uh
and something that uh trolls and others
cannot comprehend so because you know
they probably can't even read past the
first page but yeah so this is
definitely a heavy read but definitely
worthy of your time okay
let's see what else here um okay so
let's go into some other things here
uh let's talk about more like
philosophical topics but related to
specific subjects so the first one i
want to bring is really interesting by
jeremy waldron
and i first started reading this book at
the university of georgia
um
and
it's actually quite fascinating with
respect to how the united states views
free speech and also the rest of the
world so this is interesting it's called
the harm in hate speech it's actually a
philosophical argument for why hate
speech needs to be banned in the united
states and generally globally
um
i think it's a really good read it's
it's backed by a lot of evidence
it showcases a lot of historical
accounts and
data with respect to how hate speech
actually influences society and the
inevitable results of that
uh of course the most extreme example
being the the holocaust and other such
things
um but yeah definitely one of the only
books on the subject okay that i've
found
really fascinating
um so uh yeah
definitely something to look into and no
hate speech is not necessarily banned in
the united states
the uk european nations and other
nations deal with hate speech very
differently from the united states the
united states has a lot less
restrictions on what it what counts as
hate speech okay so
there you go that's interesting
all right so
now let's talk about something a little
bit more dreary um terrorism
so the first
one of the first works that i've read on
trying to look at terrorism from a
philosophical standpoint how to define
it and what it really is was by igor
primoratz this is a fascinating book
terrorism philosophical investigation
it's quite concise but it's also very
heavy in terms of its thinking tries to
define terrorism and what it exactly is
and i use it in my own research so i
definitely recommend this as well it's
well written and it has pretty robust
argumentation
okay
all right then um
another book about terrorism all right
this one is more from a psychologist
perspective and there are other books
that she's written but this is her the
one that kind of shot her to fame so the
psychologist ann speckhard and i
mentioned this book
another stream recently it's
okay by the way this is going to
intimidate you okay
so talking to terrorists uh so she's
understanding the psychosocial
motivations of militant jihadi
terrorists mass hostage takers suicide
bombers and martyrs so she examines
mostly suicide bombers what their
mentality is whether they're actually
motivated by religious thinking or
there's a psychological issue at play
she comes to the conclusion that islam
has little to nothing to do with suicide
bombing and terrorism in general by
examining
a number of psychological profiles of
actual people regarded as terrorists
so she actually went into battlefield
she actually
interviewed and did psychological
examinations of people who
who were considered to be terrorists or
conducted terrorist acts
and she came to conclusion that islam
really has nothing to do with it and
that they have specific mental traits
that push them down in that that way and
usually has to do with grievances with
regard to being terrorized themselves
so this is a fascinating book she also
did a book about isis members i haven't
actually purchased that one yet
unfortunately i have it in pdf
but yeah um yeah great book
something to look into um this book is
called talking to terrorists so it's
actually a scientific evaluation
using real data and evidence
to showcase that ideology plays little
role in the motivating factor behind
terrorist acts
okay so that's
that's a big book there
oh god okay so all right so now all the
uh depressing stuff's out of the way
of course the first couple of books
weren't really depressing but those were
kind of uh but you know that's for your
own interest i have more books on
terrorism and isis and things like that
we may go over those later
in the next video but in the meantime
let's go into fiction books yay
and some of you already know some of the
fiction books that i love um
so
let's see here uh
uh
this book is actually about islamic
history it's a fiction book about
islamic history
what happened with andaluse
and the reconquista and it's by torik
ali it's called shadows of the
pomegranate tree or the yeah pomegranate
tree
and uh this is um
a very interesting book uh in that it
explains the
the perception of muslims during the
time of the reconquista and when the
genocide was being committed
so this is an issue it's very sad but
it's well written i think that you would
enjoy this
yep
there you go
let's see um you know about the other
books i'm about to mention here but i'm
going to mention them anyway i don't
think i've mentioned these in last
streams
so
uh the books that i've loved when i was
younger
the book series that i loved when i was
younger more than anything
was a fantasy novel and many of you have
heard me talk about in the past but uh
something that i consider better than
harry potter itself i don't care what
people say harry potter is nonsense
compared to this
uh and that is red wall by brian jacques
okay
so
this is by far the best
young adult
fantasy series
i think ever written
my personal opinion
uh you can disagree that's fine but uh
yeah anthropomorphizes
um
animals basically uh and it's more like
a medieval setting
um but it's really well written um it's
really good for kids it teaches about
heroism and
and honor and dignity and
you know what it means to be a moral
person you know with uh duty and you
know things like this so it's it's it
has a lot of traditional
um
values placed therein and uh you know if
you like stories about nights and
you know fighting for the week and
things like that and you know mystery
and finding sacred you know weapons and
things like that
this is the book that you should start
reading for your children and you can
also read it yourself it's actually
quite a good yarn um and so i recommend
these books there's a whole series of
those like over 20 books in the series
so
but this is the first one this is the
one that started them all so
red wall so if you want to see if you
like the series start this one first
maybe if you have kids start them on
this one first and see how they like it
and then after that you can you know
see if you want to get the rest all
right then
last but not least
probably a book that's going to be very
controversial here
not because of the content but because
some people find it extremely boring
or they find it to be one of the best
written books of all time
um so
um
here we go
the the book in question is moby dick
yeah moby dick
um
i know many of you have already heard of
this book by herman melville
one of the classic american novels uh
very well written um extremely well
written
um considered to be the quintessential
american novel classic
uh full of a lot of theological imagery
and it's just a generally good story
about
man mankind
uh about uh man's limitations uh man's
struggles
and uh purpose in life etc so i it's a
highly right it's one of my favorite
books of all time obviously i've read it
a few times
and
yeah i if if you can get through it i
recommend it um
it's actually not this big this is
actually large type but
um it's a little bit it's a it's a
fairly big novel but it's it has a lot
of this has everything that a story
could offer you with respect to
adventure and
you know dread and you know just
hope and love and just everything so
it's it's a very um
it's a very fascinating book they're in
fact it's so fascinating that there are
some parts of it that it just seems like
they don't fit in but in fact they do
so for example he has a whole chapter
here so moby dick's about hunting a
whale that's the general gist of it um
but he has a whole chapter here where he
discusses
body parts of a whale so the whole
chapter is just dedicated to dissecting
whales the anatomy of a whale and you're
wondering why is it there
and it's actually a metaphor for trying
to understand
the attributes of the divine because
the whale plays the role of being a
metaphor for god
and ahab plays a metaphor of being like
someone who hates god and wants to fight
god
and how they're unsuccessful in doing so
and
so yeah there's a lot of theological
imagery here so you have to read into
the symbols and stuff like that so it's
a very deep book it's not like you know
you just read the story you get the
story and that's it there's a lot of
stuff you have to think about so that's
why for some people it may not be um an
attractive read
but uh it is interesting and i think
that it is one of the deepest books ever
written so
that is uh what i would recommend as the
top classical novel
and that's
really it
those are the books that i want to
recommend for this video
i have quite many more to recommend in
the near future
but i think that will be
sufficient for now
and i hope that you enjoyed those
recommendations so
any questions before we go
i have been reading the
chat
and i will eventually be posting these
uh recommendations in the information
box for those of you who just want to
see the the recommendations and go to
the links to purchase these books
so no worries about that
all right
i really don't see any
other questions here so i will be ending
this stream uh thank you very much for
listening